traditionelles vereinbart worden die
Tagesordnung um die in der
zusatzpunkte-liste aufgeführten Punkte
zu erweitern von der Frist für den
Beginn der Beratung soll soweit
erforderlich abgewichen werden die
Tagesordnungspunkte 4 11 und 15 sowie
Tagesordnungspunkt 23 Buchstabe e werden
abgesetzt die weiteren Änderungen und
Ergänzungen sowie den geänderten Ablauf
der Beratung im Übrigen können Sie der
zusatzpunkte-liste entnehmen ich mache
schließlich auf einen nachträgliche
Überweisung im Anhang zur
zusatzpunkteliste aufmerksam ich sehe
keinen Widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe nun auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
1 Befragung der Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung hat uns mitgeteilt dass
heute der Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf Scholz
zur Verfügung steht Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben das Wort für ihre einleitenden
Worte
Präsidentin meine verehrten Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zunächst mal möchte mich
bei Ihnen allen bedanken für die Arbeit
die sie das ganze Jahr über bisher
geleistet haben noch sind wir nicht ganz
angekommen in der Sommerpause diese
Sitzungswoche wird noch mit vielen
vielen Entscheidungen verbunden sein
aber ich weiß dass viele Dinge die wir
hier auf den Weg gebracht haben und die
Gesetzgebung werden mussten hier
verhandelt worden sind und noch
verhandelt werden deshalb danke dafür im
übrigen
[Applaus]
im übrigen
spielt die viele Arbeit ja auch wieder
was notwendig ist um unser Land zu
modernisieren um dafür zu sorgen dass
wir auch in 10 20 30 Jahren noch gute
Arbeitsplätze haben dass wir es schaffen
den Menschen gemacht und Klimawandel
aufzuhalten und vorne dabei zu sein wenn
es etwa um Digitalisierung geht und
moderne Produktion von Halbleitern zum
Beispiel alles das haben wir möglich
gemacht und das spiegelt sich auch
nieder in dem Haushalt den wir heute als
Bundesregierung als Entwurf beschlossen
haben und den Bundestag zugeleitet haben
der hat Prioritäten die offensichtlich
sind zuallererst geht es um die
Sicherheit unseres Landes
der russische Angriffskrieg ist eine
Zeitenwende weil die
Sicherheitsarchitektur Europas dadurch
unmittelbar bedroht ist und sie hat
viele Konsequenzen mit sich gebracht zum
Beispiel dass wir viele Mittel aufwenden
um die Ukraine zu unterstützen
finanziell humanitär aber auch weit
Waffenlieferung und das muss finanziert
werden bisher aber auch für die Zukunft
denn niemand kann vorhersagen wie lange
dieser Krieg noch dauert und wir müssen
dann diese Aufgabe auch Schultern aber
ganz besonders gilt das natürlich auch
im Hinblick auf die Notwendigkeit die
Bundeswehr zu stärken und das haben wir
gemacht möglich mit einem Sondervermögen
das der Bundestag hier auch mit
verfassungsändern da Mehrheit auf den
Weg gebracht hat und das jetzt ganz
zügig ausgegeben wird damit die
Bundeswehr Stellen gestärkt werden kann
perspektivisch auch das Spiegel dieser
Haushalt schon wieder wird es so sein
dass wir dann diese Aufgaben laufend aus
den Mitteln des Bundeshaushalt des
finanzieren müssen und auch darauf sind
vorbereitet auch das ergibt sich aus dem
Haushaltsentwurf über den wir dann
sorgfältig mit der Ihnen diskutieren
können aber Sicherheit ist eine große
Herausforderung und natürlich bedeutet
das auch Hausherr Herausforderung für
den gesamten übrigen Haushalt denn
dieser Aufgaben sind ja alle
dazugekommen wäre das nicht so wäre
manches viel einfacher zu handeln aber
es ist notwendig dass wir uns dieser
Aufgabe stellen und dass wir das
Notwendige für die Sicherheit unseres
Landes für die Ausstattung der
Bundeswehr für die Stärke der Allianz
der NATO tun und das tun wir
die zweite Priorität ich habe es eben
schon in meiner Eingangsworten gesagt
ist wir müssen dafür sorgen dass wir
einen erfolgreiches Industrieland
bleiben mit modernen auch neue
aufzubauenden und zu entwickelnden
Industrien dass wir 2045 CO2-neutral
wirtschaften und das geschieht mit einem
massiven Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien offshore onshore mit dem Ausbau
der Solarenergie mit dem Ausbau unserer
Übertragungsnetze der Verteilnetze mit
dem Aufbau von lade Infrastrukturen mit
dem Startschuss für ein wasserstoffnetz
mit den Entscheidungen für neue
Kraftwerke die das gesamte Stromnetz
ergänzen werden als Wasserstoff ready
Gaskraftwerke mit der Entscheidung dafür
Sorge zu tragen dass Investitionen in
der Industrie stattfinden Nummer auf
andere Weise Stahl zu produzieren Chemie
zu machen Zement her zu stellen und auch
etwa die Elektromobilität voranzutreiben
alles das machen wir in großem Umfang
und das spiegelt sich in diesem Haushalt
auch wieder und ich will das noch mal
ergänzen im Hinblick auf die notwendigen
Investitionen in unserem Land weltweit
haben viele verstanden dass wir
resilienter werden müssen und das ist
deshalb auch bestimmte Industrien gibt
die notwendigerweise bei uns angesiedelt
sein sollten in Europa und eben auch in
Deutschland und dass wir jetzt ein Trend
haben Halbleiterindustrie Investitionen
in Europa und ganz besonders in
Deutschland zu tätigen das ist eine gute
Sache die wir auch unterstützen es gibt
um die Investitionen die wir haben im
Saarland in Sachsen in Sachsen-Anhalt
viele viele Halbleiter Fabriken werden
in Deutschland entstehen das ist eine
gute Botschaft in einer Zeit in der
manche nicht sicher sind wie geht es
voran mit unserem Industrieland doch das
passiert und dafür sorgen wir
und die dritte die dritte Bemerkung die
ich gerne machen möchte in diesem
Zusammenhang ist dass wir für den
Zusammenhalt unserer Gesellschaft sorgen
dass wir alles Notwendige tun dass alle
zu recht kommen können dass jeder sich
sehen fühlt und dass jeder weiß es geht
auch um ihn selbst wir haben das gemacht
mit erheblichen Steuererleichterung
gerade für kleine und mittlere Einkommen
mit zum Beispiel eine Entscheidung dass
die Rentenbeiträge nicht mehr abgezogen
werden vom steuerpflichtigen Einkommen
mit Entlastung bei den
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen für
diejenigen die weniger als 2000 €
verdienen und wir haben es auch gemacht
mit sozialpolitischen Reformen wie dem
Bürgergeld dem Wohngeld das jetzt
Erwerbstätigen die geringe Einkommen
haben und Renten und Rentnern viel mehr
Unterstützung gewährleisten kann mit den
Kindergeld der Kindergeld Erhöhung für
das erste zweite dritte Kind dem
Kinderzuschuss und dann auch natürlich
im Fragen der Mobilität solche Maßnahmen
wie dem deutschland-ticket das jetzt
überall zur Verfügung steht also wir
haben aktiv etwas für Zusammenhalt getan
und werden das auch weiter tun deshalb
deshalb gehört zu den Vorhaben die wir
haben auch zum Beispiel dass wir jetzt
alles dafür tun die Kinder
Grundsicherung nach den ersten Schritt
mit dem Kindergeld und dem
Kinderzuschlag auch zu vervollständigen
die Regierung wird die entsprechenden
Würfe sehr frühzeitig und rechtzeitig
bis Ende August fertigstellen so dass
die Reform dann Anfang 25 in Kraft
treten kann ein ehrgeiziges Vorhaben
aber ein Vorhaben das für die
Gerechtigkeit und unserer Gesellschaft
sorgen kann man sieht also Sicherheit
wirtschaftlicher Wohlstand und
industriepolitische Zukunftsfähigkeit
Klimaneutralität und Zusammenhalt das
sind die wichtigsten Merkmale eines
Haushaltes der natürlich davon
herausgefordert ist dass sich in den
letzten Jahren viele auch an die großen
Dimensionen gewöhnt haben die mit den
Bekämpfungsmaßnahmen
im Hinblick auf die Bekämpfung der Kurve
19 Pandemie und ihrer wirtschaftlichen
und sozialen Folgen aber auch mit den
Maßnahmen zur Abfederung der
Konsequenzen des russischen Krieges
gegen die Ukraine in unserem Land
verbunden sind ob es nun der Bau neuer
lng-terminals ist ob es die
Subventionierung durch den Weltmarkt
sonst viel zu hoher Gas und
Energiepreise ist alles das haben wir
gemacht und das ist eine große
Herausforderung gewesen etwas was
niemand unserem Land zugetraut hat dass
wir das schaffen sicher durch den
letzten Winter zu kommen aber es ist
jetzt auch klar dass wir nun wieder
Haushalte aufstellen werden die nicht
mit diesen zusätzlichen
kreditfinanzierten Mitteln versuchen
Krisen zu bekämpfen sondern die sich
ganz konkret auf die Zukunft unseres
Landes ausrichten und das ist der
Bundeshaushalt den wir jetzt vorgelegt
haben
[Applaus]
vielen Dank ich mache bevor ich die
erste Fragestellerin Aufrufe noch mal
kurz darauf aufmerksam dass ich bitte
alle an die vorgegebenen Zeiten halten
für die erste Frage eine Minute für die
Antwort eine Minute für die Nachfrage 30
Sekunden und auch für die Antwort nur 30
Sekunden ich bitte darauf zu achten und
jetzt beginnt mit der ersten Frage aus
der cdu/csu-fraktion Dorothee Bär
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler für uns ist das Elterngeld
eine der größten Familien und vor allem
auch frauenpolitischen Errungenschaften
der letzten Jahre wir haben das
eingeführt 2007 als unionsgeführte
Bundesregierung und das war dafür
geplant
Einkommensverluste durch ein Baby
abzufedern insbesondere für gut
ausgebildete junge Frauen damit Paare
ermutigt werden sich fürs Kind zu
entscheiden damit Paare ermutigt werden
sich dann für Kind und Karriere auch
entscheiden zu können ihre angekündigte
Entscheidung jetzt in dieser Woche
trifft vor allem die Mitte der
Gesellschaft ins Mark die
Leistungsträgerinnen in unserer
Gesellschaft diejenigen die auch wieder
die Steuern zahlen damit auch die hohen
Sozialleistungen gezahlt werden können
und deswegen frage ich Sie warum glauben
Sie dass ausgerechnet in diesem
Bundeshaushalt an Familien gespart
werden muss an Kindern gespart werden
muss und warum wollen Sie besonders die
Leistungsträger abstrafen
[Applaus]
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage zunächst mal
würde ich gerne unterstreichen dass das
Elterngeld in der Tat eine große
sozialpolitische Innovation ist die wir
in Deutschland immer weiter entwickelt
haben insbesondere soll sie auch dazu
beitragen dass mehr Männer sich dafür
entscheiden Kinder zu betreuen und das
kehrarbeit nicht ausschließlich eine
Sache von Frauen ist
bei der Konzeption der heutigen Fassung
ist es so dass wir eine Einkommensgrenze
haben von etwa 300.000 Euro das ist sehr
sehr viel und es hat in den letzten
Jahren immer wieder die Frage gegeben ob
die nun wirklich genau und richtig
bemessen ist deshalb ist es glaube ich
ganz vernünftig dass man über die
richtige Kalibrierung dieser Reform auch
in einzelnen Details weiter diskutiert
wichtig ist dass wir den Kerngedanken
den wir mit der elterngeldreform
verbinden nicht vergessen und der geht
darum dass wir mehr Eltern ermutigen
dass sie ihre dass sie Kinder bekommen
dass Sie sich entscheiden das geht durch
eine gute betreuungsstruktur aber
selbstverständlich auch dadurch dass
Frauen und Männer sich gleichermaßen um
ihr Kind kümmern
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen das
war zwar nicht die Antwort auf meine
Frage aber wir sind auch für Männer in
der Erziehung vielleicht noch als
Nachfrage sie haben in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag unter anderem
festgehalten dass sie das Elterngeld
dynamisieren wollen dass ihre
Arbeitsmarkt gleichstellungs- und
Familienpolitik der Hörenden
Erwerbsbeteiligung auch von Frauen zum
Ziel hat und deswegen muss ich noch mal
nachfragen wie sie als Kanzler der
angeblichen fortschrittskoalition
verantwortlich dass sie nun mit einer
Entscheidung fürs Baby wieder die Frauen
mehr in die Abhängigkeit ihrer Männer
treiben was ja offensichtlich gar nicht
ihr Ziel ist und wie verantworten Sie
das Ganze
schönen Dank schönen Dank für Ihre Frage
aber die in die Frage eingebauten Fakten
Informationen stimmen nicht wenn ich mir
das erlauben darf zu sagen es ist in der
Tat so dass die Bundesregierung sich
sehr entschieden vorgenommen hat dass
das Elterngeld sich dynamisch
weiterentwickelt das werden wir auch tun
und wir haben uns außerdem vorgenommen
dass wir eine Situation haben in der
Frauen und Männer diese Möglichkeiten
noch nutzen dazu haben wir immer
gesetzgeberische Reformen vorangebracht
und ich wiederhole noch mal es geht
darum dass wir allen das ermöglichen und
deshalb ist die Frage ob 300.000 eine
richtige Einkommensgrenze ist sehr
berechtigt sie hat mit der Fragestellung
und den Fakten die Sie da gesagt haben
ziemlich wenig zu tun
eine zweite Nachfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion stellten Nadine schön
Kanzler sie haben wieder von der
Kindergrundsicherung gesprochen sie
versprechen Respekt und die
Kindergrundsicherung ganz konkret
schleifen sie aber Programme die ganz
gezielt die bildungsschancen von Kindern
in unserem Land betreffen und ich hoffe
wir sind uns einig das Geld allein noch
keine Chancen schafft sondern dass es
vor allem darauf ankommt dass wir die
Bildungschancen verbessern in ihrer
Regierungszeit haben sie aber die
sprachkitas gestrichen sie haben setzen
die Angst an den digitalpakt Schule
aufholen nach Corona wurde ersatzlos
gestrichen die Lehrerbildung wird jetzt
auch noch gestrichen das sind alles
Programme die konkret für die
Bildungschancen für Kinder wichtig sind
meine Frage ist ist das der Respekt für
Familien und Kinder in unserem Land
schönen Dank auch für diese Frage in der
Tat ist es wichtig dass in unserem Land
die Gemeinden die Länder die im
Wesentlichen die Verantwortung für
Schulen Krippen und Kitas haben alles
dazu beitragen dass wir vorankommen mit
einem flächendeckenden Angebot an
Krippen und Kitas mit der Möglichkeit
dass sie bezahlbar sind und dass sie
möglichst gebührenfrei sind dafür habe
ich mich als Regierungschef eines der 16
Länder eingesetzt und das auch real
umgesetzt was in vielen Ländern noch
nicht getan worden ist und wir werden
weiter dafür sorgen dass es auch
vorangeht mit dem Ganztag in den
Grundschulen und deshalb ist es immer
wichtig dass zeitlich befristete
Programme der Bundesregierung zu
Unterstützung der Aktivitäten der Länder
und Kommunen immer wieder neu kalibriert
werden denn es bleibt ja dabei das in
der verfassungsrechtlichen Zuständigkeit
die Länder für die Entwicklung dieser
Programme da sind und wir werden weiter
aktiv sein deshalb sind Mittel
vorgesehen für das Stadt
chancen-programm das kommt bei Ihrer
Frage nicht so richtig raus aber es ist
so und deshalb plant die Ministerin auch
dass sie wieder ein Neuansatz finden
kann mit der digitalen Unterstützung
insofern ist Ihre Frage an jemanden
gerichtet der nicht hier steht
die nächste Frage
geht in die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und kommt von der Kollegin
lamiacador
Bundeskanzler
ich habe eine frage zum
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt sie
haben ja gerade angesprochen für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt ist es
ja von zentraler Bedeutung dass alle
Menschen darauf vertrauen können dass
sie von staatlichen Stellen
gleichermaßen geschützt werden und auch
nicht diskriminiert werden und das gilt
übrigens für alle eben logischerweise
Land und Kommunen für die Verwaltung
unseres Landes arbeiten Menschen die
sich jeden Tag und seit Jahren gute
Arbeit machen und sich auch nicht leicht
machen wenn nun aber PolitikerInnen oder
Politiker an die Spitze von kommunalen
Verwaltung kommen die Verdacht der
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit stehen könnten
oder gar stehen oder als gesichert
rechtsextreme extrem Geld gelten und die
politische Berechnung von Minderheiten
zum Beispiel fordern wächst ein Gefühl
von Drogen wir dürfen nirgendwo zulassen
das Vertrauen in die Integrität von der
Verwaltung oder von Verwaltung insgesamt
verloren geht und dass wir die
Demokratie engagierte Menschen geschützt
werden was ist zu tun für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt aus
ihrer Sicht um diesen Bedrohungen und
Einschüchterungen entgegenzuwirken und
Minderheiten und Menschen die sich eben
für diese Demokratie engagieren und im
Verwaltung Arbeiten zu schützen
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage zunächst mal
sind
Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaften dafür
da Bürgern und Bürger zu schützen auch
diejenigen die tätig sind im
öffentlichen Dienst und die tätig sind
an den Spitzen der Verwaltung vor
Bedrohung das dürfen wir nicht hinnehmen
und deshalb muss die ganze Härte des
Rechtsstaats gegen jeden eingesetzt
werden der solche Bedrohungen
organisiert verantwortet dazu aufruft
oder etwas ähnliches tut
gleichzeitig ist es sehr sehr wichtig
dass wir auch wissen dass es unser aller
Aufgabe ist wir müssen als Gesellschaft
insgesamt couragiert sein und müssen
denen auch entgegentreten die auf solche
Weise gewalttätig sind und ein Klima von
Verängstigung zu erzeugen versuchen und
deshalb will ich Ihnen gerne sagen ich
bin mit in bedrückt über Angriffe die
auf Kommunalpolitikerinnen und
Kommunalpolitiker ausgeübt werden über
das was ihnen geschieht genauso wie all
das was wir als Gewalt erleben z.B gegen
diejenigen die Rettungseinsätze
durchführen die als Feuerwehrleute tätig
sind oder Polizistinnen und Polizisten
wir müssen als Gesellschaft zusammen
stehen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
dank frau Präsidentin ja ich habe
tatsächlich noch eine Nachfrage sie
sagten vorhin dass alle Menschen in
diesem Land sich zurecht fühlen und dass
jeder gesehen wird das finde ich sehr
löblich zum Thema gesellschaftlicher
Zusammenhalt was wäre denn aus ihrer
sich Kriterien Werte
Maßnahmen meinetwegen oder Prinzipien
die uns tatsächlich in unserer
Einwanderungsgesellschaft ja sehr
vielfältig ist zusammenhält
für mich bedeutet
das Zusammenhalt der Zusammenhalt
unserer Gesellschaft erstmal dass wir
uns dafür
verantwortlich fühlen dass alle eine
gute Zukunft haben und deshalb ist die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes die
Frage ob wir für wirtschaftliches
Wachstum sind ob wir glauben dass
angesichts der Globalisierung und aller
technologischen Veränderungen für alle
ein Platz sein wird mit guten
Arbeitsplätzen ganz zentral aber es
gehört auch dazu dass wir dafür Sorge
tragen dass jeder seine Möglichkeiten
nutzen kann durch einen gerechtes faires
Schulsystem das unabhängig vom
Elternhaus Laufbahn möglich macht durch
immer wieder neue Angebote für Bildung
Ausbildung und Weiterbildung aber auch
dadurch dass wir zum Beispiel
wertschätzen welche Leistung diejenigen
die nach Deutschland gekommen sind für
unseren eigenen Wohlstand bisher schon
geleistet haben und auch künftig leisten
werden und mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz nutzen wir der
deutschen Volkswirtschaft sondern wir
sagen auch wir sind dankbar für das was
seit Jahrzehnten in Deutschland passiert
ist
Wohlstand wäre kleiner wenn wir nicht
auf diese vielen Arbeitskräfte und diese
vielen Talente in Deutschland
zurückgreifen können
Herr Bundeskanzler auch bitte auf die
Zeit ein bisschen draufgucken das wäre
wichtig damit auch alle die hier
gemeldet sind zu Ihrer Frage kommen und
der nächste aus der afd-fraktion ist
Steffen Portrait
frau Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler wir
haben eine Inflation von sechs bis acht
Prozent wir haben eine Idee
Industrialisierung wir haben weltweit
die höchsten Energiepreise wir haben
Investitionsstau bei Schulen z.B von 45
Milliarden Euro und nun verdonnern sie
die Menschen dazu Wärmepumpen mit den
zugehörigen Kosten einbauen zu müssen
die Grünen versuchen gerade in ihrer
Partei zentrale so eine Wärmepumpe seit
Jahren einzubauen klappt nicht so
richtig die Kosten laufen aus dem Ruder
sind genauso hoch wie das gesamte Haus
50% aller Häuser sind dann eben mit
diesen Kosten verbunden von 100.000 €
aufwärts und schon allein die Zinsen für
die Kredite übersteigen dann die
eingespartner in der Energie und auch
die eingesparte Tonne CO2 wird erkauft
auf diesem Weg mit 12 bis 14000 Euro
sie sie verdonnern die Bürger diese
Kosten aus sich zu nehmen Sie
bringen Sie damit um die Früchte ihrer
jahrelangen Arbeit sie wollen die
Unabhängigkeit auch damit in Frage
stellen und wie bewerten Sie diese wie
bewerten Sie diese
grundgesetzwidrige Enteignung der Bürger
schön Dank für Ihre Frage ich kann dich
auf alle Falschbehauptung eingehen aber
ich will zu den Kernfragen etwas sagen
erstens
erstens ist es so dass wir in der Tat
ein Thema Inflation haben das kommt
durch die Entwicklung der weltweiten
Lieferketten das kommt durch die
gestiegenen Energiepreise aus aller Welt
und das hat etwas zu tun mit den
krisenbekämpfungsmaßnahmen aller
Volkswirtschaften auf der ganzen Welt
wegen Corona wegen auch jetzt das
russischen angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine und deshalb unterstütze ich sehr
die ganz klare Haltung der Zentralbanken
insbesondere der Europäischen
Zentralbank gegen die Inflation
vorzugehen wir können nicht immer weiter
leben mit diesen Null sind Situationen
und deshalb ist es richtig aktiv gegen
die Zinssteigerung und und aktiv gegen
die Preissteigerung auf diese Weise zu
agieren zweitens kommt darauf an dass
wir für billige Energie sorgen und das
machen wir in Deutschland indem wir uns
nicht abhängig machen von den immer
teureren Importen für Kohle Gas und Öl
sondern die erneuerbaren Energien
ausbauen die sehr billig Strom
produzieren können und Energie
produzieren können Deutschland wird 2030
80 Prozent seines Stroms aus
erneuerbaren Quellen schaffen und dann
werden wir ein richtiges
strommarktdesign vorausgesetzt auch in
der Lage sein sehr billige im weltweite
Maßstab sehr billige Energiepreise und
Strompreise zu haben
zur mehr können Sie jetzt nicht mehr
ausführen weil die Zeit abgelaufen ist
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen 30
Sekunden
Bundeskanzler ich muss sie korrigieren
Inflation ist zum Großteil hausgemacht
schauen sie an die Inflation in der
Schweiz viel viel geringer dann zu den
Energiepreisen die haben sie
hochgetrieben haben wir an dieser Stelle
aber schon behandelt sie reden von
wasserstoffnetzen und eben auch von
Wasserstoff Heizung die sind aber nicht
in Sicht und werden ökologisch sinnvoll
auch gar nicht kommen niemand weiß
welche Heizungsart er jetzt einbauen
kann weil die kommunale wärmeplanung
noch fehlt sie wollen eine CO2 einsparen
verbieten aber die Kerne Energie und wie
erklären Sie sich diese
schildbürgerstreiche in der Politik
danke dass Sie eine Nachfrage stellen
dann kann ich nämlich auf die ganzen
vielen Dinge die sich schon in ihrer
ersten Frage untergebracht haben doch
noch eingehen also es ist ganz klar aber
30 Sekunden ja ja die Frage war länger
aber ich mache es also es ist ganz klar
dass es viele viele gute Möglichkeiten
gibt zu heizen das kann man zum Beispiel
Fernwärmenetze machen mit
Tiefengeothermie da habe ich mehrere
Anlagen gesehen die da geplant sind und
einige eingeweiht wir können das machen
mit mit Solar Wärme vom Dach wir können
das machen mit den Möglichkeiten der
Wärmepumpe wir können das machen mit
Netzen die dann immer weniger Gas und
fossile Energien benutzen und darum ist
die kommunale wärmeplanung genau der Weg
dazwischen dann kann man als Bürger als
Bürger kennen was passt bei mir am
Besten und es wird dann immer die
billigste und vernünftigste Lösung sein
die man sehen kann
die nächste Frage stellt aus der
SPD-Fraktion Lena Werner
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler vor ungefähr
zwei Wochen wurde ja in Einigung mit
Intel erzielt das ist damit die größte
ausländische Direktinvestition die das
Unternehmen tätig dies in Deutschland
jemals gegeben hat bisher über 30
Milliarden Euro sollen dabei investiert
werden 9,9 Milliarden Euro kommen aus
der öffentlichen Hand das ist natürlich
für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
ein starkes Signal für die Region im
Osten auch und die Region um die um
Magdeburg herum mich würde jetzt
interessieren wie Sie diese Investition
bewerten und was sie sich davon für die
Region erhoffen schönen Dank ich will
gerne sagen dass es schon ein
beeindruckendes Zeichen ist dass so
viele
deutsche und internationale Unternehmen
sich zur Ausweitung ihrer
Halbleiterproduktion gerade in
Deutschland entscheiden ich habe schon
berichtet im Saarland war das wolfsbeet
im Dresden wo ja schon ein Silicon
Valley existiert hat Infineon noch mal
eine milliardenschwere Investitionen
angekündigt und bereits auf den Weg
gebracht und jetzt kommt noch das mit
Intel dazu ich weiß von weiteren
Vorhaben deutscher Unternehmen und viele
anderer und wenn das passiert dann
werden wir uns weniger abhängig machen
von den Halbleiter Lieferung aus anderen
Regionen und gleichzeitig all die
Kompetenzen und Fähigkeiten in
Deutschland auch sichern die man braucht
um für eine der wichtigsten Technologien
der Zukunft auch selber gut gerüstet
sein all die schlechten rufe überwies
uns demnächst gehen wird werden durch
die Investitionen in die
Halbleiterindustrie in Deutschland Lügen
bestraft
meine Nachfrage stellen vielen Dank
welche Rolle hat denn der Zugang zur
erneuerbaren Energien bei der Standort
Entscheidung gespielt gerade wenn man
das was ja wahrscheinlich auch in Bayern
geprüft wurde als vergleichen nimmt
die Entscheidung des Unternehmens kann
am Ende nur das Unternehmen erläutern
seriöser Weise aber in der Tat dass wir
perspektivisch billigen Strom haben der
aus erneuerbaren Quellen kommt spielt
für wie viele viele
Investitionsentscheidungen eine zentrale
Rolle das ist bei der Batteriefabrik die
jetzt in Schleswig-Holstein errichtet
wird der Fall gewesen das ist bei den
Investitionen eines amerikanischen
elektromobilfahrzeugs Herstellers in
Brandenburg der Fall gewesen das ist bei
vielen anderen der Batterieproduktion
der Fall gewesen und hier auch und heute
können wir sagen dass durch die hohe
Produktion von Strom aus Windkraft und
Solarenergie im Norden und Osten
Deutschlands dort strukturell geringe
Energiepreise aufgerufen werden die
sicher verfügbar sind und würde es schon
so sein dass wir unsere
Übertragungsnetze durch ganz Deutschland
gezogen hätten und die Stromproduktion
im Süden und Südwesten auch entsprechend
auf Windkraft vorangetrieben würde dann
hätten wir diese billigen Preise überall
in Deutschland
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
DIE LINKE Heidi reichlinik
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler Scholz es
mag sie nicht überraschend dass wir als
Linksfraktion eine Frage zur
Kindergrundsicherung haben und ich weiß
wahrscheinlich sollte ich die eher dem
eigentlichen Regierungschef dem
Finanzminister Lindner stellen aber
vielleicht können Sie mir auch
weiterhelfen denn ihre Regierung
streitet ja seit Monaten um dieses Thema
obwohl sie das im Koalitionsvertrag alle
drei Parteien das möchte ich noch mal
betonen vereinbart haben und die
Familien warten und verzweifeln und die
Verbände laufen Sturm denn das größte
sozialpolitische Vorhaben laut
Ministerin Haus droht nicht mehr zu
werden als eine Verwaltungsreform im
Koalitionsvertrag steht dass sie das
Existenzminimum von Kindern und
Jugendlichen neu berechnen wollen und
darauf basierend die Kinder und
Sicherung einrichten wollen das wäre ein
schöner Plan gewesen hätte man ihn so
durchgeführt aber bisher ist leider
recht wenig passiert und wir haben jetzt
von Frau Ministerin Haus gehört es gab
Punkte und da hat sie auch sie den
Kanzler an ihrer Seite das freut uns
natürlich aber im Haushalt im Finanzplan
20 25 ist nur eine Summe von 2
Milliarden bisher eingestellt und ich
weiß sie können mir die Summe jetzt
nicht nennen aber ich möchte Sie an
dieser Stelle fragen können sie
garantieren dass es wirklich
Leistungserhöhungen für Kinder und
Jugendliche geben wird wie das auch die
Ministerin Haus verspricht und das am
Ende mehr geben wird als diese zwei
Milliarden
also zunächst mal muss ich sie
korrigieren wenn ich das darf in der Tat
handelt es sich um ein ganz wichtiges
Projekt sowohl der Sozialdemokratischen
Partei als auch der grünen als auch der
FDP in allen drei Wahlprogrammen war die
Kindergrundsicherung angekündigt sie ist
auch ein Koalitionsvertrag gekommen und
wir haben den ersten großen Schritt
schon gemacht denn die von mir bereits
erwähnte Kindergeld Erhöhung und die
kinderzuschlagserhöhung kostet laufend
sieben Milliarden Euro das ist eine
dramatische Verbesserung der Lage von
Familien und wir
wollen jetzt neben dem was damit
gewissermaßen schon gewährleistet ist
noch eine bessere Zusammenführung
erreichen und eine Leistungsverbesserung
auch um die geht es und wie die genau
ausgestaltet sein kann darüber werden
wir uns noch in den nächsten Tagen
unterhalten aber sie können beruhigt
sich in die Sommerpause begeben wenn Sie
daraus wieder zurückkehren dann wird es
ein Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
geben
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
war ja jetzt keine richtige Antwort
deswegen vielleicht noch mal auf eine
abstrakteren Ebene also wir haben fast 3
Millionen Kinder und Jugendliche in
diesem Land die in Armut leben jedes
fünfte Kind jeder fünfte Jugendliche das
sind alles bekannte Zahlen deswegen die
Frage glauben Sie tatsächlich das mit
einer Verwaltungsreform und das ist das
was die zwei Milliarden die gerade im
Raum stehen irgendwie leisten können
dass damit wirklich Kinderarmut bekämpft
werden kann
Sie liegen falsch wenn sie über das was
sie gar nicht kennen sagen es ist nur
eine Verwaltungsreform aber sie werden
es ja kennenlernen und dann werden Sie
es einfach nicht mehr sagen das sage ich
mal vorher so aber das zweite das zweite
ist wir haben schon sehr viel uns
vorgenommen denn das wichtigste dafür
dass Kinder nicht arm sind sind dass
ihre Eltern Arbeit haben das ist das
worum wir immer kämpfen darum geht es
auch bei kinderbetreuungsausbau und
modernen familienpolitiken und das
zweite ist dass wir versuchen hinzu
herbeizuführen dass eine Situation
entsteht in der Kinder nicht auf die
Leistung der Grundsicherung zu Struktur
angewiesen sind also des Bürgergeldes
wie das heute der Fall ist und genau das
werden wir erreichen mit der schon von
ihnen abgefragten Leistungsverbesserung
die nächste Frage stellt aus der
FDP-Fraktion Konstantin Kuhle
Herr Bundeskanzler ganz herzlichen Dank
ich habe eine frage zum Gebäude
Energiegesetz das wird ja an diesem
Freitag voraussichtlich hier im
Deutschen Bundestag beraten und eine der
wesentlichen Verbesserungen die im
parlamentarischen Verfahren erreicht
werden konnten ist der Vorrang der
kommunalen wärmeplanung es wäre absurd
von den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zu
verlangen sich hier besonders zu
engagieren bevor der Staat selbst seine
Hausaufgaben gemacht hat um allerdings
die kommunale wärmeplanung vorzunehmen
braucht es ein wärmeplanungsgesetz mich
interessiert wie die Meinungsbildung in
der Bundesregierung zu diesem Wärme
wärmeplanungsgesetz voranschreitet wann
wird die Bundesregierung dieses
werbeplanungsgesetz vorlegen und
beschließen und wie will die
Bundesregierung damit umgehen dass es
möglicherweise kleine Kommunen gibt die
bis 2028 gar keine kommunale
wärmeplanung vorlegen können
zunächst mal will ich gerne
unterstreichen dass sich ihre Ansicht
teile dass die kommunale wärmeplanung
von größter Bedeutung ist das merkt man
ja auch daran dass viele Kommunen in
Deutschland schon angefangen haben das
zu machen es gibt ja auch schon solche
die das realisiert haben und deshalb ist
es etwas was wir aufgreifen wenn wir das
mit einem rechtlichen Rahmen Regeln für
ganz Deutschland und dann auch
vernünftigerweise den Zusammenhang
herstellen zu den Entscheidungen die bei
der gebäudeenergie von den Eigentümern
der Gebäude zu treffen sind und deshalb
arbeiten wir jetzt mit Hochdruck daran
dass dieses Gesetz sehr schnell kommt
wir waren sehr weit und sind es auch
noch aber haben abgewartet wie jetzt
konkret das Gesetz aussieht das am
Freitag hoffentlich im Bundestag
beschlossen wird und auf dieser Basis
ist bereits die Regierung dabei das
Gesetz entsprechend vorzulegen für die
Kommunen die sehr klein sind gibt's ja
vor allem um die Frage der Perspektive
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger wird Ihnen
das irgendwann zum Nachteil reichen und
da werden wir dann wird es möglich sein
dass die auch ihre Entscheidung treffen
können selbst wenn keine vorgelegt
worden ist
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
ja ich würde in der Nachfrage gerne die
europäische Perspektive mit einbeziehen
die CDU geführte Europäische Kommission
unter Ursula von der Leyen arbeitet ja
auch am Thema
gebäudeenergie am Thema wärmeplanung und
hier steht jetzt im Raum das ist ein
Verkaufsverbot geben soll für Gasheizung
obwohl wir gerade mit dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz das Gegenteil beschließen
wollen nämlich das auch klimaneutrale
Gasheizung eingebaut werden können das
gleiche gilt für Pelletheizung die
verboten werden sollen durch die
Europäische Kommission obwohl Heizen mit
Holz weiter erlaubt sein soll gut dass
wir das am Freitag beschließen wollen
wie gehen wir damit um das auf
europäischer Ebene hier anders
vorgegangen wird wie wird sich die
Bundesregierung in den Gremien der
europäischen Gesetzgebung positionieren
Bundesregierung hat es mit ihrer
Positionierung in den Gremien der
europäischen Gesetzgebung nicht so
schwer weil wir ja gerade ein Gesetz
beschließen dass der Maßstab für unser
Abstimmungsverhalten sein wird
[Applaus]
nächste Frage stellt aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion Julia Klöckner
frau Präsidentin Herr Bundeskanzler
die wirtschaftliche Lage in unserem Land
muss uns allen Sorge bereiten nur die
Bundesregierung scheint das anders zu
sehen sie sprachen jüngst noch von guten
wirtschaftlichen Aussichten und kommen
wir zu den konkreten Fakten Rezession in
Folge steigende Inflation steigende
Arbeitslosenzahlen trotz Sommer wir
haben Kapitalabfluss wie noch nie und
wir haben lohnten Nebenkosten also die
Sozialabgaben für Beschäftigte
Unternehmen die steigen und steigen
haben längst die 40
Prozentmarke überschritten sie lächeln
gerade ich finde es nicht zum Lächeln
wir hatten gerade mit Unternehmern
Gespräche dazu das ist sehr sehr
bedrückend
[Applaus]
in dieser wirtschaftlich so schwierigen
Zeit
fragen wir uns wann kommt ein
Wahlversprechen von ihnen wirklich zum
Tragen wenn nicht zwei Jahre danach sie
haben vier Cent industriestrompreis
versprochen und deshalb die konkrete
Frage wann führen Sie ihn ein
schönen Dank für die konkrete Frage frau
Präsidentin wenn ich wirklich für mich
bemühen würde die ganze aufgezählte
Liste von nicht richtigen Behauptungen
zu widerlegen können mich nicht mit der
kurzen Zeit aus deshalb beschränke ich
mich mal auf die letzte Frage in der Tat
wir haben jetzt alle Voraussetzungen
dafür getroffen dass Deutschland im
globalen Wettbewerb geringe Strompreise
haben kann sie sehen wie wir eben schon
gehört haben dass im Norden und Osten
Deutschlands ist möglich ist für
Unternehmen sehr konkrete Zusagen im
Hinblick auf sehr billige Strompreis
Lieferung zu machen ohne das zu
subventionieren weil die Windenergie so
ausgebaut ist dass wir billige Energie
haben wenn wir jetzt all die
Versäumnisse der letzten Jahre
aufarbeiten mit den Gesetzen die dazu
führen dass die Verbindungsleitung von
Nord nach Süd gebaut werden wie das
endgültige transformationsstromnetz
übertragungsstromnetz für ganz
Deutschland 2,45 definieren werden wenn
der Windkraft Aufbau im Süden
Deutschlands gelingt dann können wir
genau das machen nämlich billige Preise
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
für die kleinen mittelständischen
Unternehmen die Handwerker aber auch für
die Industrie sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen
vielen Dank sie weichen aus konkrete
Frage gerne konkrete Antwort sie haben
vier Cent versprochen der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat sechs Cent
versprochen die fdp-lint es komplett ab
darf sich jetzt ein Unternehmer was
aussuchen von den drei angeboten oder
kommt der industriestrompreis mit vier
Cent ganz konkret wenn ja und wann genau
und wenn Sie noch Zeit hätten sagen sie
gerne was welche Behauptung der Fakten
vorhin falsch war leider habe ich die
Zeit dafür nicht weil ich glaube jetzt
genau 30 Sekunden habe aber ich habe es
schon in meiner eingangsbemerkung
gemacht es war eigentlich gar nicht so
richtig richtig aber unabhängig von
dieser
unabhängig von dieser konkreten
Feststellung will ich noch mal sagen ja
es gibt jetzt schon Unternehmen die
Verträge schließen wo sie sehr billigen
Strom in dieser Preiskategorie einkaufen
können und ja es ist schon so dass wir
sehr billige Strom Möglichkeiten haben
da wo die Produktion gering ist und das
werden wir ermöglichen das entsprechende
Verträge auch abgeschlossen werden
können wir bauen all die Versäumnisse ab
die in der Vergangenheit gewesen sind
weil man den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien behindert hat wir kriegen
billigen Strom und ich wiederhole einen
Satz den ich schon mal gesprochen habe
aber die CDU-Fraktion hat jedes einzelne
Windkraftanlage in Deutschland
persönlich bekämpft und darunter leiden
wir auch noch heute
jeder einzelne eine zweite eine zweite
Nachfrage eine zweite Nachfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Klaus Wiener ja
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler Frau Klöckner hat gerade
schon das Thema Sozialabgaben
angesprochen da würde ich gerne noch mal
nachhaken in der letzten Regierung der
sie auch angehört haben da muss man ja
auch mal wieder mal dran erinnern hier
hat man eine kann man eine
sozialgarantie ausgesprochen 40% Deckung
wir stehen jetzt schon bei 40% Prognosen
sagen 43 % bis zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode 50% bis 2040 was
machen Sie ganz konkret um dem
entgegenzuwirken machen sie nämlich
nichts kriegen sie sich in Deutschland
ein neues Deutschland Tempo sondern ein
blaues Wirtschaftswunder
na also wenn ich das doch noch mal sagen
darf in der letzten Regierung habe ich
als Finanzminister möglich gemacht dass
wir mit zig Milliarden Subventionen die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge absenken
damit sie in der Krise nicht in die Höhe
und durch die Decke schießen
und ganz klar war wahrscheinlich nicht
jedem CDU-Politiker das
dauer-subventionen mit Kreditaufnahmen
von 200 Milliarden Euro im Jahr keine
gute Idee sind
nächste Frage kommt aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen sahina was
ganz klar ich möchte mal folgendes sagen
dieser Tagesordnungspunkt heißt
Befragung der Bundesregierung und ich
finde es schon wirklich ausgestattet mit
einem erheblichen Maß an Arroganz dass
sie hier Fragen die in klipp und klar
gestellt werden schlichtweg nicht
beantworten und ich erwarte von Ihnen
aus Respekt aus Respekt vor diesem Haus
dass sie sich die Mühe geben schlichtweg
diese Fragen zu beantworten der Kollege
Wiener hat eben eine Frage gestellt und
sie haben 0,0 geantwortet und wir warten
jetzt bitte eine Antwort frau
Präsidentin
[Applaus]
gebe jetzt noch mal wenn der
Bundeskanzler das wünscht noch mal
konkret zu antworten 30 Sekunden
noch kürzer machen ich habe die Frage
beantwortet allerdings sind allerdings
ist es nicht richtig die Antworten
falsch zu machen weil man das
CDU-Programm vorliest das keine Lösung
für diese Probleme sieht
sie fordern sich Milliarden Euro
Schulden dafür dass man Subventionen
macht fordere ich nicht
so bevor das bevor das jetzt ein
Zwiegespräch wird gehen wir weiter in
der
rednerreihenfolge Bündnis 90 die Grünen
stellen jetzt die nächste Frage shahina
Gambia
Präsidentin
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler
wir erleben das gerade die politische
Lage ist sehr herausfordernd ähm
besonders wenn es um den
gesellschaftspolitischen Bereich geht
wir erleben zurzeit in Deutschland einen
rasanten Anstieg wenn es darum geht um
rassistische und rechtsextreme Angriffe
und Übergriffe und ähm aus meiner Sicht
müssen wir da ganz klar die
Diskriminierung auf allen Ebenen
entgegentreten und Teilhabe und
Repräsentanz organisieren demokratie
lebt von den Menschen die sie tragen und
eine starke Zivilgesellschaft ist ein
Bollwerk gegen den Rechtsextremismus und
jede Form von gruppenbezogener
Menschenfeindlichkeit deswegen müssen
wir die Stärken die unsere Demokratie
stärken und resilienter machen deswegen
ist meine Frage nach dem Umsetzungsstand
der Gesamtstrategie der Bundesregierung
gemeinsam für Demokratie und
Rechtsextremismus und dass die nächsten
Schritte diesbezüglich sind
ja schönen Dank für die Frage zunächst
mal wissen sie dass die Bundesregierung
an demokratie-fördergesetz auf den Weg
gebracht hat das jetzt im Haus beraten
wird ich gehe davon aus dass diese
Beratung bald konstruktiv abgeschlossen
und vorangebracht sind aber da muss ich
mich als Regierung ein wenig
zurückhalten aber ich bin ganz
zuversichtlich dass das im Haus gelingen
wird und im übrigen ist es so dass wir
natürlich all die Dinge die wir uns
vorgenommen haben im Bereich
Antidiskriminierung und anti Rassismus
auch als Teil unserer Arbeit weiter
fortsetzen werden das war richtig und
natürlich wie sie gesagt haben wird es
noch richtiger durch all die Dinge die
wir gegen libertätig erleben
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
[Applaus]
Präsidentin vielen Dank für die Antwort
Jungs ist ja bekannt geworden in
Sachsen-Anhalt dass die Zahl von
Rechtsextremen Vorfällen an Schulen
tatsächlich ein Höchststand erreicht hat
und das zeigt sich in vollen von
nazi-symbolik von Hasskriminalität und
Volksverhetzung da auch noch mal die
ganz konkrete Frage was wir auch im
Bereich des Jugend und Erwachsenenalter
im Bereich der Demokratie Bildung tun
können um der Radikalisierung oder
Radikalisierung vorzubeugen im Sinne der
Radikalisierung
Schulen Kindergärten viele Dinge die
jetzt hier angesprochen wir sind gehören
in den unmittelbaren
Verantwortungsbereich unserer Länder
Gemeinden die wir aber dabei
unterstützen wollen zum Beispiel mit dem
Demokratie fördergesetz das ja dazu ein
ganz wichtigen Beitrag leistet aber ich
bin auch sehr überzeugt davon dass wir
uns darauf verlassen können dass die
Landesregierung dass diejenigen die vor
Ort tätig sind auch ganz aktiv etwas
dafür tun dass niemand bedroht wird von
solchen Dingen in den Schulen in
Kindergarten
dass man dagegen vorgeht und ich bin
auch den dankbar die Vorfälle die damit
zusammenhängen öffentlich machen und
Bedrohungslagen ansprechen weil das für
eine funktionierende Zivilgesellschaft
eine funktionierende Demokratie
unverzichtbar ist
nächste Frage stellt aus der
afd-fraktion DR Gottfried Curio
Verfassungsschutzpräsident Haldenwang
hat im ZDF erklärt nicht allein der
Verfassungsschutz ist dafür zuständig
die Umfragewerte der AFD zu senken
hierzu betont Staatsrechtler Lindner von
der Uni Augsburg Haldenwang habe Zitat
bei öffentlichen Äußerungen das Gebot
der politischen Neutralität zu beachten
Verfassungsrechtler Böhmen Nestler von
der Uni Oldenburg sagt Zitat Haldenwang
überschreitet seine Kompetenzen ganz
klar seine Aufgabe ist zu beobachten
Material zusammenzufassen den
entsprechenden Stellen zur Verfügung zu
stellen dass der Verfassungsschutz aus
politischen Gründen agiert wäre
verfassungswidrig und der
Inlandsgeheimdienst dürfe sich Zitat von
der Politik nicht instrumentalisieren
lassen finden Sie es in Ordnung einen
derart unangemessen nicht objektiv
agierenden Beamten noch im Amt zu
belassen oder ist es Ihnen als Mitglied
einer SPD die den aktuellen Umfragen
zwei Prozent hinter der AFD liegt sogar
ganz recht das Halten Wang ein
politischen Mitbewerber
fernsehöffentlich im Wege des
Amtsmissbrauchs angreifen
ist ein objektiver unabhängiger Beamter
der seine Aufgaben wahrnimmt wie ist das
Gesetz und das Grundgesetz vorschreibt
und ich will ausdrücklich sagen
natürlich gehört
gehört zu den Aufgaben des
Verfassungsschutzes das Beobachten das
berichten und das öffentliche sprechen
über die eigenen Erkenntnisse das sind
auch die Dinge um die es dann da geht
und ansonsten bin ich ganz
zuversichtlich sie werden bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl nicht anders
abschneiden als bei der letzten
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
rücken Sie den Knopf noch mal
Ministerin sagte bei der Vorstellung des
verfassungsschutzberichts der
Rechtsextremismus seit deshalb die
größte Gefahr für die Demokratie weil er
sich gegen die demokratische
Grundordnung Gerichte wörtlich das tun
die anderen extremismusformen eben nicht
dabei besagt das Verfassungsschutzgesetz
dass die Behörde nur Bestrebungen
beobachtet die sich gegen die
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
richten als Definition von Extremismus
finden Sie es in Ordnung wenn der
Bundeskanzler eine derart inkompetente
Innenministerin im Amt beläst oder passt
zu jemand einfach zu dem wie beschrieben
agierenden
ich will noch mal ausdrücklich sagen
dass die Arbeit sowohl das
Verfassungsschutzes und als auch der
Innenministerin wirklich tadellos sind
in dieser Frage und sie sind sehr
engagiert die Gefahren für Demokratie
durch den rechten Extremismus wie
übrigens auch den linken Extremismus
sehr klar zu bekämpfen und dafür zu
sorgen dass Tendenzen die unsere
Verfassungsordnung bedrohen auch
angesprochen werden und dass wir alle
unsere Möglichkeiten nutzen die
Verfassung zu schützen und deshalb
gehört das Beobachtung auch von
Bestrebungen innerhalb von Parteien die
unter das
rechtsextremismuskriterium Fallen zu den
Aufgaben dieser Institutionen und
Behörden aber das wo wir erfolgreich
sein werden und zwar sagt das jetzt mal
alle anderen Parteien hier im Hause ist
dass wir für das werden was für die
Zukunft unseres Landes wichtig ist dabei
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger überzeugen
und die übergroße riesige Mehrheit der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes hat
nicht Zeit hatte mit irgendwelchen
extremistischen Positionen
nächste Frage stellt aus der
SPD-Fraktion Tanja machalet
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Bundeskanzler in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten waren ja
viele Vorschläge zur Rente zu hören
Anhebung des Renteneintrittsalters
Kopplung an die Lebenserwartung oder
eben auch die Forderung nach Abschaffung
der sogenannten Rente mit 63
was halten Sie von diesen Forderungen
insbesondere mit Blick auf die Menschen
die tagtäglich hart arbeiten wie
insbesondere im Pflegekräfte
Reinigungskräfte Menschen hier im
Bauarbeiten dachdeckerinnen Dachdecker
schönen Dank für die Frage wer heute mit
17 die Schule verlässt mit einer
Berufsausbildung beginnt oder gleich
direkt mit der Arbeit hat 50 Jahre vor
sich das ist die Konsequenz dass das
Renteneintrittsalter jetzt festgelegt
ist auf perspektivisch 67 aber ich finde
wenn man das so sagt dann muss es auch
eine Klarheit geben es wird und soll
keine weiteren Anhebung des
Renteneintrittsalters geben das wäre
unverantwortlich
und das müssen auch alle diejenigen
wissen können die heute mit 17 mit der
Arbeit anfangen weil das ja doch eine
lange Strecke ist die sie da vor sich
haben und gleichzeitig glaube ich dass
es deshalb auch falsch ist wenn man
gewissermaßen die Stabilität des
Rentenniveaus in Frage stellt die
Regierung hat sich deshalb vorgenommen
dass wir ein stabiles Rentenniveau auch
für die Zukunft garantieren und das
werden wir auch weiter tun und wenn
jemand der ganz lange sehr fleißig war
etwas früher als andere in Rente gehen
kann ohne Abschläge befürchten zu müssen
dann kann man das noch so viel
kritisieren es ist ein Stück der
Gerechtigkeit gut dass es so ist
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja die
Angleichungen der Rentenwerte Ost und
West und damit eben der zentralen
Stellschraube für die Rentenhöhe ist
früher gelungen als geplant darüber
haben wir in der letzten Sitzungswoche
hier auch debattiert wie bewerten Sie
dies und was bedeutet das für die
Angleichung oder weitere Angleichung der
lebensverhältnis in Ost und West
zunächst mal ist es ein großer Moment
dass wir jetzt diese Angleichung der
Rentenwerte haben das ist eine Sache
nach der wir lange gestrebt haben und
dass sie jetzt sogar vor der Zeit und
der ursprünglichen Planung geschieht ist
auch glaube ich ein gutes Zeichen für
die Einheit unseres Landes
und wir müssen dafür Sorge tragen dass
aber das weiter unterfüttert bleibt denn
die Lohnerhöhung die zum Beispiel auch
durch den höheren Mindestlohn zustande
gekommen sind haben einen wichtigen
Beitrag zu dieser Entwicklung geleistet
und deshalb sage ich wir müssen auch
dafür Sorge tragen dass die Löhne und
Gehälter im Osten Deutschlands auch auf
gleiches Niveau kommen wie im Westen
Deutschlands das ist in vielen Fällen
noch nicht der Fall und das muss eine
Verpflichtung unserer Regierung aber
auch des ganzen Hauses sein
vielen Dank die nächste Frage geht in
die Fraktion Die Linke und die nächste
Frage stellt Susanne
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin der
Bundeskanzler wir sind uns
wahrscheinlich relativ schnell darüber
einig dass Löhne am besten über
Tarifverträge festgelegt und vereinbart
werden manchmal ist aber auch der
gesetzliche Mindestlohn nötig und sie
haben im Wahlkampf viel darüber
gesprochen auch viel über Respekt
erzählt jetzt ist es aber so dass die
Erhöhung auf 12 Euro vom letzten Jahr
durch die Inflation wieder komplett
aufgefressen wurde und genau in dieser
Situation die mindestlohnkommission im
übrigen gegen die Stimmen der
Gewerkschaften eine mickrige Erhöhung im
Centbereich für das nächste Jahr
vorsieht das wird dazu führen dass
Millionen Beschäftigte mit niedrigen
Löhnen massiv für Einkommensverluste
haben werden und ich frag sie was werden
Sie unternehmen damit aus dem
Mindestlohn nicht erneut einen
Armutslohn wird und damit ihr Respekt
Versprechen nicht weiter ist als Schall
und Rauch
schönen Dank für die Frage ich will noch
mal daran erinnern es war die
Sozialdemokratische Partei der ich die
Ehre habe angezogen gehören die
gefordert und durchgesetzt hat dass es
in Deutschland überhaupt Mindestlöhne
gibt es war die Sozialdemokratische
Partei hier ist sich zum Ziel gemacht
hat dass wir jetzt mit einem einmaligen
Schritt den Mindestlohn auf 12 € anheben
das stand auf meinen Wahlplakaten und im
Oktober des letzten Jahres ist das
umgesetzt worden
und ich fände es okay wenn die Partei
DIE LINKE das möglich fände auch mal
eine Sekunde zu sagen ist ja ganz okay
aber im übrigen ist es so dass wir
gesagt haben wir kehren wieder zu
Entscheidungspraxis der
mindestlohnkommission zurück die hat für
das kommende und übernächste Jahr eine
Erhöhung vorgeschlagen mit Ihnen
gemeinsam empfinde ich das nicht als den
richtigen Schritt und deshalb will ich
sagen es wäre schön wenn die Kommission
sich wieder darüber verständigt nur
einvernehmliche Entscheidung zu treffen
das ist für Anerkennung und Akzeptanz
von großer Bedeutung
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
die Arbeitgeber in der Kommission haben
die Gewerkschaften niedergestimmt haben
damit die Tarifautonomie mit Füßen
getreten und sie haben auch den
Gesetzgeber ignoriert weil sie nämlich
die 12 € nicht als Ausgangsbasis
genommen haben und für mich stellt sich
schon die Frage wollen sie sich am
Nasenring von den Arbeitgebern durch die
manische ziehen lassen oder wäre es
nicht vielleicht doch überlegen wird die
60% des mittleren Einkommens wissen die
Richtlinie der EU vorschlägt als
Untergrenze in des Mindestlohngesetz
aufzunehmen das muss ja bei den
Entscheidungen auch nach der
gegenwärtigen Gesetzeslage bewertet und
berücksichtigt werden und deshalb will
ich noch mal sagen einer der großen
eines der großen großen Kraftquellen
unseres Landes ist die
Sozialpartnerschaft und auch die
Tarifautonomie und Sozialpartnerschaft
funktioniert am besten partnerschaftlich
nämlich indem man da wo es drauf ankommt
gemeinsame Entscheidungen trifft und
dazu rufe ich auf dass es wieder dazu
kommt
nächste Frage stellt aus der
FDP-Fraktion dr anveruschka Jurisch
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Herr Bundeskanzler der Deutsche
Bundestag hat in der vergangenen Woche
das Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
beschlossen und damit eines der
wichtigsten Vorhaben der Koalition im
Bereich der erwerbsmigration beschlossen
und in der Koalition stellen wir damit
jetzt die Migrationspolitik vom Kopf auf
die Füße es wird einfacher in unseren
Arbeitsmarkt einzuwandern und den
Bereich der fluchtmigration gab es
ebenfalls auf Ebene der EU wichtige
Durchbrüche im Bereich der der
gemeinsamen europäischen Asylpolitik es
muss ja jetzt gelingen im Trilog zum
europäischen Asylsystem jetzt zügig vor
den EU-Wahlen das auch weiter
abzuschließen was das wäre jetzt meine
Frage was unternimmt die Bundesregierung
um hier eine zügige Beschlussfassung
herbei zu befördern und welche im
mpk-beschluss vom Mai verabredet in
Maßnahmen müssen darüber hinaus auch
jetzt noch umgesetzt werden um die
Kommunen in Deutschland die ja auch
weiterhin unter Druck stehen nachhaltig
zu entlasten vielen Dank
schönen Dank sie verweisen auf die sehr
fortschrittliche Politik im Umgang mit
Migration und Zuwanderung die die
Regierung sich vorgenommen hat und in
der Tat ich glaube das
fachkräftezuwanderungsgesetz ist eine
der ganz großen Innovationen die in
Deutschland stattfindet es sichert den
Wohlstand von morgen und deshalb ist es
eine gute Sache dass wir das gemeinsam
als Regierung und Parlament hinbekommen
haben es ist auch gut dass nach vielen
vielen Jahren ein
solidaritätsmechanismus unter den
europäischen Mitgliedstaaten verabretbar
waren denn das ist ja dass der Kern des
Vorschlages der den die Innenminister
und Innenminister in Europa gemacht
haben und jetzt geht's darum dass wir
das hinkriegen eine gemeinsame
Entscheidung mit dem Parlament zustande
zu bringen da bin ich ganz
zuversichtlich und meine Zuversicht ist
durch die Beratung in dem in der bei der
Zusammenkunft der Regierungschefs in der
letzten Woche noch mal gestärkt worden
denn es waren die beiden Länder die
skeptisch waren die das schon im Rad
fahren aber alle anderen haben sich dazu
bekannt dass wir mit einer
qualifizierten Mehrheit im Rat und mit
einer Einigung mit dem Parlament die
Gesetzgebung jetzt hinkriegen können
letzte Bemerkung auf den letzten Teil ja
letzte bemerken auf den letzten Teil der
Frage wir haben uns all die Vorhaben die
ich den Ministerpräsident und
Ministerpräsidenten zu beschließen
vorgeschlagen habe und die dort
gemeinsam festgelegt worden sind
vorgenommen und arbeiten jetzt Stück für
Stück ab
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank in dem erwähnten mpk-beschluss
wurde ja auch vereinbart Georgien und
Moldau zu sicheren Herkunftsstaaten zu
benennen die Einstufung dieser beiden
Ländern zu sicheren Herkunftsstaaten
hätte ja auch eine große
Entlastungswirkung im
Migrationsgeschehen und könnte auch
rechtssicher bei uns umgesehen umgesetzt
werden Georgien Moldau sind Länder die
eine Perspektive haben
EU-Beitrittskandidaten zu werden die
Menschen aus diesen Ländern können
weiterhin bei uns Asylanträge stellen
und was meines Erachtens in der Praxis
ja noch wichtiger ist die Menschen
können mit einem Visum können visumsfrei
in unseren schenkenraum einreisen und
dann bei Bedarf auch Asylantrag stellen
meine Frage ist wann wird die
Bundesregierung ein entsprechenden
Gesetzesentwurf vorlegen
zunächst mal möchte ich
Ihrer Schilderung ausdrücklich zustimmen
ich teile die Bewertung der Lage wie sie
das Sagen und will noch gerne ergänzen
dass ich auch wahrgenommen habe dass
beide Länder gerne auch von sich aus als
sicherer Herkunftsländer
Herkunftsstaaten eingestuft werden
würden wir arbeiten deshalb jetzt an dem
Prozess dass Vorhaben in eine
Gesetzestext zu fassen und werden das
den Bundestag zügig zu lassen
die nächste Frage stellt aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Günter Krings
der Bundeskanzler am 23 mai diesen
Jahres wurde die Zahlen kindlicher
Gewaltopfer als Auswertung der
Polizeilichen Kriminalstatistik 2022
vorgestellt danach werden in Deutschland
noch immer jeden Tag 48 Kinderopfer
sexueller Gewalt bei der Herstellung
bei dem Besitz und der Verbreitung
kinderpornografischen Materials gab es
im letzten Jahr insgesamt
42.75 Fälle und damit ein Anstieg
gegenüber dem Jahr 2021 von 7,4 Prozent
Praktika bis hin zum bka-präsidenten
weisen darauf hin dass häufig die
IP-Adresse der einzige Ermittlungsansatz
ist der überhaupt zum Täter führen kann
ich zitiere den bka-präsidenten
Verfahren müssen derzeit eingestellt
werden mit dem Risiko das noch
andauernde Missbrauchstaten nicht
unterbunden werden können ich frage Sie
daher warum bleiben sie untätig und
nehmen Tag für Tag in Kauf Das Kinder
weiterhin missbraucht werden können weil
die Täter wegen fehlender IP-Adressen
Speicherung nicht ermittelt werden
können
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage sie sprechen
ja in der Tat ein sehr schlimmes ernstes
Thema unserer Wirklichkeit an und ich
finde wir dürfen nicht wegsehen
sexual Missbrauch sexueller Missbrauch
an Kindern ist eine fruchtbare Tatsache
im Leben zu vieler Menschen und gerade
zu vieler Kinder und deshalb haben wir
auf alle Weise etwas dafür zu tun dass
wir das verhindern und dass wir die
Kinder schützen aber dass wir die Täter
auch ergreifen können und dass wir sie
der Gerechtigkeit und den Gerichten
zuführen können deshalb wird in der
Bundesregierung gegenwärtig darüber
diskutiert wie wir eine möglichst
geeignete Lösung finden können um die
jetzt durch die Rechtsprechung erkennbar
gewordenen Handlungsoptionen zu nutzen
ohne dass wir dabei rechtsstaatliche
Fragen missachten das ist nicht ganz
trivial aber ich bin ziemlich
überzeugt dass die frage ihn bald ganz
konkret beantwortet werden kann mit sehr
konkreten Details
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen das
tue ich ja gerne angesichts des ernsten
Themas und die Bewertung teilen wir ja
hätte ich mir wirklich heute eine
konkretere Antwort sehr gewünscht
ihr Kanzleramtsminister hat anders der
regierungsbefragung am 8 Februar hier in
diesem Hause angekündigt dass die
gesetzgeberische Umsetzung sehr zeitnah
geschehen werde das fast ein halbes Jahr
her und nach fast fünf Monaten ist es
dringende Problem eben immer noch nicht
angegangen geschweige denn gelöst sie
schauen dem Streit weiter tatenlos zu
zwischen Justiz und Innenministerium sie
lassen die Ermittler damit und die
Kinder mit dem Problem bislang im Stich
von daher die ganz konkrete Frage wann
machen sie die Rettung missbrauchter
Kinder hier durch mindespeicherung von
IP-Adressen zu ihrer Sache zur einer
Chefsache im Kanzleramt wann legen Sie
den Bundestag eingesetztentwurf vor
ich habe die Antwort auf Ihre Frage eben
schon gegeben und wiederhole was ich
eben gesagt hat kann ihn aber bestätigen
dass ich sehr sorgfältig die fachlichen
Debatten die auch mit sehr viel
Kompetenz geführt werdende zwischen den
beiden Ministerium verfolge und mich an
den Debatten auch beteilige und darum
kann ich Ihnen auch sagen dass ich die
Zuversicht habe dass wir eine gute
Lösung haben werden die alles
Erforderliche ermöglicht aber
gleichzeitig wie gesagt alle
rechtsstaatlichen Fragen auch
berücksichtigt und die sind nicht ganz
einfach
eine zweite Frage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion stellt Michael
Breilmann
Herr Bundeskanzler ein halbes Jahr ist
seitdem vereitelten mutmaßlich
islamistisch
extremistischen Anschlagsversuchen
Castrop-Rauxel vergangen und die
Sicherheitsbehörden konnten den
Tatverdächtigen mittels einer IP-Adresse
identifizieren aber nur aufgrund der
Tatsache dass diese zufälligerweise noch
nicht gelöscht war und nicht nur in
meinem Wahlkreis Castrop-Rauxel sondern
in eine ganz Deutschland fragen sich die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger deswegen auch
wann bewegen Sie sich bei einer
gesetzlichen Regelung zu Pflicht von
Speicherung von IP-Adressen es besteht
ein dringender Bedarf sehen sie auch
aufgrund dieses Vorfalls einen
dringenden Handlungsbedarf planen Sie
eine Speicherpflicht von IP-Adressen zu
Terrorismusbekämpfung
zu regeln und wenn ja bis wann ganz
konkret
danke für Ihre Frage die sie stellen und
die ja anschließend an das was ihr
Kollege vorher schon gefragt hat deshalb
ist in der Frage der Technik die Antwort
die gleiche wie sie jetzt nicht weiter
verwundern wird aber ich will
ausdrücklich sagen dass ich ja mehrfach
wenn der Vergangenheit mich daran
beteiligt habe entsprechende
Gesetzgebung auf den Weg zu bringen
manche davon sind vor Gericht
gescheitert später und lange ausgesetzt
gewesen auch in der letzten
Legislaturperiode wegen der
gerichtlichen Verhandlung dieses Themas
das beweist wie schwierig das ist und
dass man nichts falsch machen darf aber
weil die Dringlichkeit eine gute Lösung
zu haben auch groß ist versichere Ihnen
dass Sie diese Fragen auch gut
beantwortet werden bekommen von der
Regierung und das wirklich mit großen
Nachdruck und großen Ernst an der Sache
gearbeitet wird
vielen Dank im Bundeskanzler die nächste
Frage stellt die Kollegin Sandra der
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
herzlichen Dank Herr Präsident sehr
geehrter Bundeskanzler meine Frage zielt
auf die Allianz für Transformationen die
sie in ihrem Haus verantworten sie
sprechen dort mit Unternehmen mit
Wissenschaft aber auch mit
Gewerkschaften Sozialpartnern darüber
wie Transformationen in Deutschland
gelingen kann das ist der Weg den wir
gemeinsam als Koalition geben wollen mit
allen Kräften nach vorne ich möchte sie
gerne fragen welche Einblicke sie aus
den Gesprächen bisher gewinnen konnten
wie die zentralen Maßnahmen der
Bundesregierung auch über das letzte
Jahr jetzt bewertet werden dort und
welche Maßnahmen vor allen Dingen mit
Blick auf die Zukunft da entscheidend
sind wie zum Beispiel ein
industriestrompreis und wie diese
Debatte ihrem Eindruck nach dort sich
darstellt
schönen Dank und in der Tat das ist eine
gute Gesprächssituation ein gutes
gesprächsformat wo wir Erfahrungen
austauschen wissenschaftlich
Erkenntnisse mit einfließen lassen
Erkenntnisse aus den Unternehmen von
allen Beteiligten und deshalb ist es für
uns immer wieder anders sich mit den
Herausforderungen die uns auch ansonsten
jetzt bewegen zu beschäftigen ob das nun
die Frage künstliche Intelligenz ist ob
es die Frage ist wie können wir die
Innovationsdynamik im Gesundheitswesen
verbessern was können wir tun um
Schwierigkeiten im Planungsverfahren zu
beschleunigen und allein schon am
letzten aber auch den vorherigen sieht
man das ist dann nicht nur dass wir
darüber reden und uns konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht werden sondern es ist
dann auch so dass wir dann hinterher
versuchen praktisch
Umsetzungsschritte in den verschiedenen
Ressorts auf den Weg zu bringen also für
mich persönlich bereichernd aber es
bleibt nicht beim zur Kenntnis nehmen
sondern wir gucken dann auch hinterher
immer was kann man umsetzen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin bitte
ich würde gerne einmal nachfragen im
Bezug auf das neue Klimaschutzgesetz das
ja jetzt auch mehr sektorübergreifende
Perspektiven ermöglicht und da auch
wieder aus dem Kreis
industrievertreter:innen die Sorge
geäußert worden ist dass die Industrie
vielleicht mehr an Emissionsminderung
übernehmen muss wenn vielleicht andere
Bereiche nicht so liefern würden wie
würden Sie diese Situation einschätzen
und dem entgegnen
wir haben ehrgeizige Ziele ich glaube
dass festzuhalten ist unverändert
notwendig wenn wir zwei 30 80 Prozent
des Stroms aus der neubahnen Quellen
haben wollen wenn wir 2045 endgültig
klimaneutral Wirtschaften wollen dann
bedeutet das große technologische
Sprünge riesige privatwirtschaftliche
Investitionen auch gerade im
industriellen Bereich mit neuen
Technologien die allerdings
wahrscheinlich die Exportfähigkeit und
den Wohlstand Deutschlands stabilisieren
und verbessern werden weil wir etwas
anzubieten haben was die ganze Welt
wegen des der Gefahr des Menschen
gemacht und Klimawandels braucht und
deshalb bin ich ganz zuversichtlich dass
wir mit dem neuen Klimaschutzgesetz
einen weg haben eine Gesamtbetrachtung
vorzunehmen die sowohl über die
Emissionen der einzelnen Jahre als auch
in der Perspektive es möglich macht zu
gucken wo sind die Stellschrauben wo man
schnell und am besten wirksam erreichen
kann dass das funktioniert und alles
auch hinkriegen können und ich glaube
dass dieser geschärfte Blick uns allen
nutzen wird
gibt es eine weitere nachher dass sie
sich nicht dann kommt der nächste
Fragesteller live die Fraktion
vielen Dank Herr Präsident für das Wort
Herr Bundeskanzler ich komme zurück zur
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung Deutschland
steckt in der Rezession ifo hat jetzt
seine Prognose für dieses Jahr
heruntergesetzt wir werden ein
Schrumpfen der Wirtschaft
voraussichtlich erleben um 0,4 Prozent
der Geschäftsklimaindex ist gesunken die
Auftragseingänge sind gesunken die
Exporte Insolvenzen sind gestiegen wir
erleben ein dramatischen Einbruch bei
den Investitionen es findet in
Deutschland eine d-investition statt
Kapital fließt ab der Wohnungsbau
schwächelt nicht nur sondern er rutscht
auch in eine starke Rezession die
deutschen verlieren dazu ihre Kaufkraft
wir haben weiterhin eine hartnäckig hohe
Inflation bei Nahrungsmitteln
14%, dementsprechend schwächelt auch der
Konsum Deutschland macht sich auf den
Weg der kranken Mann Europas zu werden
wo ist eigentlich das Wirtschaftswunder
dass sie den deutschen versprochen haben
zunächst mal finde ich gehört dass dazu
dass es in der Politik welche gibt die
erleben als Kassandra verbringen indem
sie sagen alles wird schlimm es geht
auch Leute die kriegen was hin und
sorgen dafür dass die Dinge besser
werden und zu denen habe ich mich immer
gezählt
das zweite was ich ihnen gerne sagen
will ist wir haben alle Möglichkeiten um
mal das eine Thema des Wohnungsbaus
aufzugreifen da findet jetzt durch die
plötzliche Zinssteigerung natürlich eine
anpassungssituation statt die nicht
einfach ist und so eine Zinssteigerung
haben wir zuletzt gehabt im Westen
Deutschlands in den 70er Jahren in so
kurzer Zeit wenn ich das richtig sehe
aber es ist trotzdem so dass wir Zinsen
haben die im Vergleich der Jahrzehnte
gering sind und bei höheren Zinsen sind
in Deutschland West und Ost 72 800.000
Wohnungen gebaut worden es wird also
gehen und deshalb haben wir auch mit den
Mitteln für den sozialen Wohnungsbau
dazu beigetragen dass jetzt dort große
Investitionen in bezahlbare Wohnung
überall in Deutschland möglich sind ich
hoffe sehr dass viele Investoren viele
kommunale Wohnungsgesellschaften viele
Genossenschaften die neuen Möglichkeiten
jetzt auch nutzen und das gleiche gilt
für all die anderen wirtschaftlichen
Fragen ich habe es hier vorhin schon
gesagt wir haben direkt Investitionen
die nach Deutschland kommen in Batterie
Fabriken in Automobilfabriken in der
Halbleiter Fabriken es spricht also
alles dagegen dass wir nicht
Wachstumsperspektiven haben wir haben
jetzt die Weichen gestellt damit das
stattfinden kann und da geht es um
hunderte Milliarden Investitionen in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten
Nachfrage bitte ja Herr Bundeskanzler
ich spreche hier von Fakten die
vorliegen und offensichtlich gibt es
hier sehr viele Kassandras die ins
gleiche Horn stoßen es gibt natürlich
die eben klar sagt wir sehen ein
Warnsignal dass der Standort Deutschland
unattraktiv wird der bdi-chef Russwurm
waren vor einer Illusion die
Energiewende könne die Keimzelle eines
neuen Wirtschaftswunders werden
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass es unsere
Nachbarn besser geht während bei uns
eben das Kapital abgezogen wird wird in
Frankreich jetzt stark investiert was
also machen unsere Nachbarländer und
unsere Nachbarländer insbesondere
Frankreich besser als wir noch mal ich
habe eben schon einzelne Beispiele
aufgezählt wo in Deutschland investiert
wird und ich könnte diese Liste sehr
umfassend verlängern wir sorgen dafür
dass es gute Investitionsbedingungen
gibt und die wichtigste Grundlage dafür
ist dass Deutschland mit seiner
strategischen Entscheidung die
strukturellen Voraussetzungen für
bezahlbaren Strom für Bürgern und Bürger
Handwerkerinnen Handwerker und große
Unternehmen überhaupt geschafft während
andere da noch große Herausforderungen
vor sich haben wo ich finde das werden
die auch schon lösen aber wir jedenfalls
haben einen Weg den wir zielgerichtet
verfolgen und wer darauf setzt kommt
denn ja in die Lage die hier schon
besprochen worden ist das ist nämlich
Unternehmen gibt dieser ich baue eine
Fabrik und wenn die 27 28 fertig ist
garantiert der Versorger mir billigen
Strom und dazu eine unsubventionierte
Zusage kriegen ein besseres Zeichen für
ein Investitionsstandort was
Energiekosten betrifft kann man ja
eigentlich nicht setzen jetzt müssen wir
dafür sorgen dass das auch voll zum
Tragen kommt und das will ich dann doch
noch mal sagen wir haben jetzt eine
Situation wo alleine wenn die großen
Übertragungsnetze in Deutschland
errichtet worden schon wären und fertig
wären wir weniger Kosten hätten für
Abriegelung mehr billigen Strom hätten
und weniger Kosten für das
nachtproduzieren schon verkauften Strom
als Windstrom im Norden eingekauft wurde
und in Süddeutschland eingesetzt wird
aber dann noch mal neu produziert werden
muss diese
Verwirrung der Vergangenheit lösen wir
auf und das ist ein ganz wichtiger
Beitrag zu einem guten Industriestandort
und dazu kommt noch das will ich dann
gerne ergänzen dass viele Länder über
Fachkräfte und Arbeitskräfte Mangel
klagen wir auch aber wir haben einen Weg
wie wir das hinkriegen können mit guter
Ausbildung und Weiterbildung hier zu
Lande aber eben auch indem wir
diejenigen Talente die wir brauchen und
in Deutschland nach Deutschland holen
damit unsere Wirtschaft wachsen kann und
unsere sozialen Sicherungssysteme stabil
bleiben
[Applaus]
so mit dieser Antwort beende ich die
Befragung die Zeit war schon abgelaufen
aber ich wollte den Bundeskanzler nicht
unterbrechen
ich dachte ich dachte die Union hat
Interesse an Antworten und nicht nur
Anfragen aber ich rufe auf ich rufe auf
den Tagesordnungspunkt 2 die Fragestunde
die mündlichen Fragen auf Drucksache 20
75 18 werden in der üblichen Reihenfolge
aufgerufen
ich rufe auf den Geschäftsbereich des
Bundesministeriums für Wohnrecht
hattentwicklung und Bauwesen zu
Verantwortung steht bereit der
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
Barthold ich rufe auf die Frage Nummer
eins ist Abgeordneten Bernd Schattner
afd-fraktion betreffen Preisentwicklung
von Wohnimmobilien im ländlichen
städtischen Raum
sie haben schon das Wort
vielen Dank Herr Präsident Herr
Abgeordneter ich beantworte Ihre Frage
wie folgt ja die Preisindizes für ein
und zwei Familienhäuser und
Eigentumswohnungen des